entering a judgment-free zone here with
reverend
sean z williams he's encouraging us to
love all humans through his new
non-profit
and here's how so how did love all
humans start
well i'm reverend sean zu williams and
back in 2012 i started with a song and
to basically define what human life
really does when humans work together
you know
it's very possible to love all humans
when you love themselves
however we're you know born and educated
in a world
where diversity and being different
is you know very well known you know you
have to be from a different society a
different group
well that's why you you can only hear my
voice you know i don't want
someone to see me and appear to a quick
prejudgment or judge uh what love all
humans is about just
by looking at me so to
to become different and to become
educated in a way
to educate human life we start
with love all humans so we are starting
a non-profit right here in las vegas so
we can educate
tourists and locals who have
uh love for not only for their families
but for other human families as well
when they come here
to vegas july 2021 we'll
have the 501 3c status to start a
non-profit organization
las vegas is the melting pot from all
cultures different foods
different ethnic backgrounds and
different religious beliefs
we all have this bond and we all have
the same it's
vegas strong so if we can be vegas
strong we can be
human strong world wide how can love all
humans assist
in today's welfares with you know top
news and negative
you know outcomes of what's going on
with with human existence well i can
tell you
i really do believe that it's going to
take time
for humans to love all humans from what
we have seen
you know on tv through our peers on
social networks all the negativity
but you know what it really starts with
one person
and then when that one person is kind to
another human being
it just it creates a better sustainable
human fellowship
worldwide we want to engage with the
frontline workers
what are frontline workers we're talking
about you know the doctors the nurses
the police officers
our our firefighters um our our armed
forces
you know uh even even our our peace and
freedom
you know people that are trying to
create peace worldwide
those are frontline workers and i
noticed that
if we can all communicate and educate
one another as human beings then we can
thrive
as a human race when you have
uh the understanding and the knowledge
to treat
other human beings with respect that's
when other human beings
will have that knowledge to actually get
it done
we're stronger together we're stronger
together as a human race so love all
humans
is here for you is here for all humans
worldwide
for more information on love all humans
call 702
or visit loveallhumans.com and last